a scientist who proved the existence of
the afterlife continues his
investigation despite the wave of
suicides he caused while his son falls
into the arms of a difficult woman
so today on cinema recap i'll show you
the discovery the film begins with an
interview with dr thomas harbour the
reporter asks him about his great
discovery knowing that there is
something after death but he replies
that he prefers to call it a new plane
of existence the reporter also tells him
that this great discovery is very
dangerous
since thanks to it several people have
committed suicide because they want to
go there but he responds that the world
deserves to know he explains that when
the body dies consciousness travels to a
new plane the one he discovered he also
says that in order to achieve this he
made a machine that can read
consciousness at a subatomic level the
reporter asks him a question that many
people in the world have and it's if he
feels responsible for the entire wave of
suicides around the world to which he
simply replies no
at that moment a young man interrupts
the interview to thank dr harper while
putting a gun to his head he pulls the
trigger but not before saying now i can
start over we see how everyone is upset
mainly the reporter who kept screaming
for help while we see dr harbor with a
surprise look and feeling some guilt
some time passes after the interview and
we meet the doctor's son his name is
will harbour who is on a ferry he is
watching tv where they're talking about
the anniversary of his father's
discovery
so far more than 4 million people have
committed suicide
they also mentioned that after the
interview they had with dr harbor a few
years ago he disappeared and has not
given any more interviews to the media
so the son is bothered by these kinds of
comments and decides to turn off the
television
after that unpleasant moment a girl
complains to him why he turned off the
television since she was watching it
so he apologizes saying that he thought
he was alone on the ferry he sits with
her for a moment to chat and tells her
that she seems familiar and she says
that maybe they met before but she
doesn't remember him then she introduces
herself as isla and he lies to her
saying that his name is will stevenson
so that she doesn't know that he is a
relative to the doctor in this talk we
can see that will does not agree with
the suicides or with his father's
discovery and when the ferry reaches a
island they were traveling to hilah says
goodbye to will a truck arrives for will
which is driven by a young man named
toby who is also a son of the doctor
they chat along the way and we learned
that the doctor has made some changes in
his investigation
which is why will wants to visit his
father
when they arrive to dr harper's building
toby explains that the place was bought
to house people who tried to commit
suicide and was turned into his father's
new center of operations
as they enter the building we can see
that there are many people working
inside and they have extreme security
since it is dangerous for the world to
know where dr harper is when will
arrives at his father's office he sees
that there is a special device that can
kill and revive his father will is
scared but toby reassures him that it's
perfectly normal in his father's test
which only lasts 15 to 30 seconds after
waking up dr harper welcomes will and
invites him into chat for a bit when
they are alone will asked him to stop
doing his research and the doctor asked
him why since he was the inspiration for
those experiments apparently years ago
will wrote a few words talking about the
afterlife but will says that they both
did wrong since they have caused a lot
of deaths
dr harper tells him that he has already
shown everyone the door to the other
world and will not stop until he finds
what's behind the door will disagrees
and goes for a walk some bad memories
come to his mind and suddenly he sees
isla who is putting stones in her
backpack and goes to the sea to try to
commit suicide
will rescues her and the girl gets upset
bashing was determined to do it will
takes isla to his father's building but
toby tells her that there are several
protocols that she has to go through in
order to accept her
at that very moment the doctor arrives
then isla realizes that he is will's
father
and he interviews her before accepting
her the questions during the interview
are pretty deep and either feels
uncomfortable
since they speak as if nothing about
suicide and loss of people
but she agrees to answer everything
meanwhile will explores the place a
little more and toby shows him his
bedroom his brother is excited because
that night some problems will be solved
and they will have a talk with the
people that's been following their
father's investigation at night dr
harbour is giving a speech to some
people and will joins the group the
doctor explains that all of them are
selected because they understand the
magnitude of his objectives and he
believes that they will be able to
support him during his investigation
then the doctor gets them all relaxed
before showing them a boy that is
connected to his machines who will be
used to show them what is beyond the
door on the other plane of existence
while they plan how to do it the doctor
says he wants to be connected to the
machine others say it's too risky and he
comments that there is another
possibility but they have to get the
body of someone who's already dead
they all comment that it's going to be
difficult to obtain that but isla says
she knows how they follow isla's
indication and arrive at a morgue where
the plan is for toby to distract the
guard while will and isla choose and
steal the body
when they're planning this they also
discuss what could be behind death's
door they choose the body and escape
from the place the plan was a success
and soon after they are home but will
and the girl continue to talk about the
afterlife isla finds out that will's
mother also committed suicide so she
kindly asked him how she did it and he
replies that on a normal day she was
found dead in the bathtub and that
everything indicates that she did not do
it because the day before it was a
parent's anniversary and the doctor
ignored her aila also confesses to will
that she had a son who accidentally
drowned on the beach so they both
comfort each other the next day they
begin to test with the body that they
stole
they connected devices to the body and
perform electric shocks to try to revive
the body's brain a little
but they are unsuccessful and the power
cuts out they all exit the evidence room
but will return for a brief moment to
see some videos on the monitors
which are being projected from the
subconscious of the dead body
will hides this from the others and
shortly before they enter he turns off
the monitors and says that it is time to
return the body so they do not find out
what he saw isla accompanies will to
return the body which is only left
outside the morgue for the caretakers to
get it and then they kiss in the car
once they're back will analyzes the
recordings that were projected on the
monitors which are images of a hospital
and begins to investigate what it means
we'll go to the hospital where the body
had its memories walking around the
place in search of the exact areas of
the videos but apparently the hospital
has changed and the corridor that was
shown in the videos are gone
he decides to return home where his
father is giving another speech but in
the audience there was a girl who was
casting doubts on the other people so
the doctor tells her that she can no
longer be in there with them the girl is
very sorry but she is still kicked out
of the place will decide to tell isla
about the recordings and that he
believes that his father's machine does
not show what is after death but only
memories of people's past
so they sneak into the hospital to see
the documents of the body they stole
later the harbor brothers talked for a
while about their father's behavior
and even though they are his children
they do not know him very well but what
is clear to both of them is that he does
not show remorse about what had happened
to their mother will then returns to his
room and sees isla who tells him that
the video is not a memory of the body
and it is something else since there is
a tattoo that the original body did not
have they keep thinking and decide to go
find relatives of the body they stole
the next day before going to look for
the relatives they first go to the sea
where will confesses that on one
occasion when he was about to die the
doctors revived him but he managed to
see things which inspired his father to
start the investigation they find the
house of the parents of whose corpse
they stole
but they can only speak with the sister
who tells him that no one at home really
loved him
then they asked her questions to confirm
details about the video but nothing
coincides as it seems that they're
talking about two different men they
both return home to talk about what
happened and about their loss of the
family members in the past
the moment becomes emotional so they
start kissing but they are interrupted
by toby who tells him that his father
was connected to the machine and they
have not been able to bring him back at
that moment they all go to the testing
room where will confesses that the
machine does work because he saw the
videos before and since the doctor
remained in that state for more than 30
seconds they can see videos coming out
of his mind which show the exact moment
in the past when he ignored his wife
during their anniversary
after which she committed suicide but
shortly after we see that dr harvard
repents and apologizes to his wife and
apparently they had a nice night but the
harbor brothers say that was not
actually what happened one man says that
he has found a way to bring him back
so they all decide to give it a try they
make several attempts until they succeed
they show the videos to their father and
they are all confused and then dr
harvard concludes that perhaps it's an
alternate reality
that when a person dies its
consciousness travels to the past and it
can change the events since in theory it
would be like a second chance this
worries everyone as it means that if
people find out they can do whatever
they want without guilt as they will
have another chance the doctor tells
everyone that it is better to destroy
the machine so the information does not
get everyone out of control as they're
at it someone tells the doctor that
people are outside asking for an
explanation of what happened so they all
go out and the doctor begins his speech
to calm them down
when suddenly the girl who was kicked
out from the place a few days before
arrives and shoots isla the girl drops
the gun and regrets it saying that she
only wanted to be accepted back
and we see that despite the doctor and
will's attempts to save isla she dies
well is very upset by what happened to
isla and decides to connect himself to
the machine and others support him so
that he does not die
will appears on the ferry and runs into
isla and tells her that he has come back
for her she explains that the first time
she got there she didn't even get off
the ferry because he didn't save her
from drowning when she committed suicide
at sea she tells him that he has been in
a cycle every time she dies he returns
to that point to try to save her and
that this cycle will end when one of
those times he manages to save her
completely and that since he already
saved her there they both will go
somewhere else but before that his
father and his brother try to bring them
back but they can't will's vision is
blurred for a moment and he appears near
a beach walking calmly when he sees a
child alone playing near the water the
child is having problems and the small
waves are knocking them down however
will reacts before an accident can
happen he takes the boy out of the water
and then we can see the mother in the
distance looking for her son when she
sees him she runs with the scared face
and we realize that it is isla
but neither one of them recognizes each
other will has just saved the life of
her son which as we know was the reason
why either wanted to commit suicide in
the future when they were traveling on
the ferry the end if you liked the video
please leave a like and subscribe to
continue receiving recaps of the best
drama movies my name is tc and i'll see
you in the next video bye